hey guys here we are is happening day 0
of e3 the coolest week in gaming on the
whole entire year now you probably
already know who I am and what show
you're watching so let's jump right into
a roundup of the EA Microsoft and
Bethesda press conferences but as this
conference was all dismemberment
customization and funnily enough only
one definitive edition whichever way you
look at it though bethesda kicked off
the conference season pretty damn strong
the presentation began with a heavy dose
of blood and gore in Doom has two showed
off the single and multiplayer plenty of
gruesome demon variants guns that packed
more than a punch and melee attacks
which proves the age-old adage that more
than one way to chainsaw through a demon
a math and game editor called doom
snapped map was also revealed as well as
a spring 2016 release window battlecry
launched into a global beta alongside a
new trailer and we got another Elder
Scrolls game that isn't the one we
wanted this time it was a strategy card
game called elder scrolls legends in the
use of things we did want Dishonored 2
is coming you'll have your pick of
protagonists between the original hero
corvo attano and emily cold win who is
featured as a child in the first game
each character has their own powers and
abilities although we're safe bet is
that either way you'll feel pretty
kick-ass Dishonored 2 launches next
spring in 2016 and it was revealed that
a definitive edition of the first game
is also underway finally fallout 4 was
paraded with a lengthy concept art
trailer and a number of announcements
including a mobile game called fallout
shelter that you can play on iOS right
now a real-life hit-boy complete with a
slot for your phone which will contact
in the collector's edition and the
fallout 4 release date that
less than five months away on November
10 that was all just the icing though
the meat of the presentation came via
the sweet looking single-player trailers
which revealed an optional gender for
the protagonist and an intense level of
customization for both the player
character as well as armor and weapon
modifications that there's also show
dolphin feature which will let you build
up your own base with various objects
however you please thanks in large part
to the fallout 4 news Microsoft was
pushed into a pretty tough spot by
Bethesda who set the bar pretty damn
high luckily enough Microsoft though
they caught the crowds attention early
with two simple words backward
compatibility Microsoft earned
themselves a pretty big applause by
revealing that xbox 360 games will
eventually be playable on Xbox one we
were also treated to new halo 5
Guardians gameplay which followed
protagonist Spartan Locke as well as the
new multiplayer mode entitled war zone
which supports up to 24 players it was
revealed that not only will fall out
fall on xbox one come bundled with
fallout 3 but it will also support mods
created on the PC the Kinect was
decidedly absent from the entire
conference although Microsoft did
highlight their hollow lens tech with an
impressive minecraft demo they also
announced they will not only be teaming
up with oculus VR but also valve vr
seemingly forming a dream team to face
off against the PS force project in war
fear the xbox elite wireless controller
was announced which is promising pro
level precision with hair trigger locks
swappable components and button and
paddle remapping a spectacularly dark
trail of the Dark Souls 3 landed along
with the info that the game will release
in early 2016 other new announcements
included key is for and two interesting
offerings from rare a rare replay
collection featuring 30 classic titles
for thirty bucks and a pirate-themed
multiplayer game
see a save microsoft also dropped a
death-defying new rise of the Tomb
Raider trailer subsequently revealing
that the game will land on November 10
and yes that is right alongside fallout
4 a new trailer landed 442 motorsports 6
alongside announcements per kg in a few
ESRI core and I on a space game by the
creator of dayz Ubisoft confirmed that
an xbox one exclusive beta for tom
clancy's the division will land in
December and as for Rainbow six siege of
free copies of rainbow six vegas and
vegas 2 will be packed in with the game
at release in the realm of definitive
editions Gears of War Ultimate Edition
is on the way designed to run at 1080p
and 60 frames per second Microsoft's
presentations proves the devs have also
well and truly discovered colors outside
of green grey and brown which is pretty
exciting for everyone Microsoft didn't
end on a spectacularly exciting note but
with the intriguing hololens and
backward compatibility reveals still
hanging in the air everyone was keen to
see what n7 and war running delights EA
was going to come up with EA started and
ended their conference very strong with
a glimpse of Mass Effect Andromeda
launching the show and an epic star wars
battlefront moment to cap it all off the
middle bits and your ability to stay
awake during them were fairly dependent
on how into sports games you happen to
be and ominous in engine gameplay
confirmed the Makos return which is
hopefully no longer a trying to link
pile of crap as well as the use of jet
packs and a release window within the
holiday season of 2016 your play is a
human of either gender exploring the
distant Andromeda galaxy hey went on to
show a slick demos and needs to speed
with the addition of a November 3
release date before switching gears to
debut a charming puzzle platformer
called unravel featuring a little woolly
dude called Yanni star wars the old
republic is getting a new story rific
expansion cold nights of
full an empire entitled bit slightly
stings for those of the streaming of
knights of the old republic three small
schemes fans had new trailers to check
out for NHL 16 FIFA 16 and NFL 16 among
others and NBA Live 16 showed off an
improved app that scans your face to put
it in the game the presentation for
Mirror's Edge catalyst was a welcome
relief to you non sports game fans it
consisted of actual gameplay videos and
a reveal that the game will feature free
roaming gameplay devoid of loading
screens or levels they also announced a
februari 23 of 2016 release dates for
catalyst finally the highly anticipated
star wars battlefront presentation
delivered gameplay footage for the first
time he showed off the massive battle of
hoth map and rounded out their
conference with a super sweet force
choke by darth vader followed by an
ethic luke skywalker vs vader faceoff
for everything i haven't managed to cram
into this horrendously long games but
news episode we shot ahead to gamespot
com for all our latest news and trailers
tomorrow I have a rundown of all the
highlights from the URI soft sony
Nintendo and Square Enix conferences so
be sure to check back then to get all
caught up
you